[Music]
you'd be forgiven for thinking that this
is one big party but for two weeks now
these protesters have laid siege to this
city
the state of emergency has now been
declared in ontario to give police more
powers to shut down demonstrations but
most insist they're not going anywhere
we can be here as long as it takes
there's
we're well supported food wise fuel wise
financially we're fully supported to be
here for as long as it takes for this
government to realize that the people
are the ones that need to have the power
the premier of ontario doug ford said he
wants people to take their children and
go home
what do you say to them
this is history in canada and this is an
important thing for them to see and them
to know these these kind of choices
shouldn't be mandated like what is the
what is the point of having a family
doctor
if the government is going to decide
what every person is going to have
it started as a protest against vaccine
requirements for lorry drivers but it's
mushroomed to an anti-government
movement which has paralyzed not only
this capital city but vital trade routes
between canada and the us
it doesn't look like much but a short
drive from the main demonstration this
repurposed car park is its headquarters
so all of a sudden we get a call and
some truckers are out of fuel and we
need to get fuel to them and so we just
rally as many people as we can winton
was a fire chief for 31 years but he's
now helping direct operations here these
are saunas you know you get cold you get
achy you get chilled and they can come
here and they can just get a little bit
of r and r
it's uh emotionally good it's physically
good
the main aim of this nerve center though
is refueling protest lorries to keep
their engines idling police raided the
camp earlier this week seizing jerry
cans containing petrol but deliveries
continue
the canadian prime minister justin
trudeau is under pressure from the u.s
to bring a swift end to this chaos the
longer the standoff continues the less
likely a peaceful resolution martha
kellner sky news ottawa